there was a scene that took place in
Congress this week that even with my low
opinion of I League
administrators exceeded even my my
lowest
expectations this would be the scene in
which ivy league university presidents
hemmed and hawed over whether calling
for the genocide of the Jews explicitly
constitutes harassment at Penn does
calling for the genocide of Jews violate
Penn's rules or code of conduct yes or
no if the speech turns into conduct it
can be harassment yes I am asking
specifically calling for the genocide of
Jews does that constitute bullying or
harassment if it is directed and severe
or pervasive it is harassment so the
answer is yes yes it is a context
dependent decision congresswoman it's a
context dependent decision that's your
testimony today calling for the genocide
of Jews is depending upon the context
that is not bullying or harassment this
is the easiest question to answer yes
Miss
McGill so is your testimony that you
will not answer yes if it uh is if the
speech becomes if the speech becomes
conduct it can be harassment yes meaning
committing the act of genocide does
calling for the genocide of Jews violate
Harvard's rules of bullying and
harassment yes or no it can be depending
on the
context no you've got this is the line
it's not even just the the lady from
Penn it's multiple University presidents
you've got multiple representatives of
the ivy league here they say well you
know what's genocide one man's genocide
is another man's freedom fighter right
that's I guess that's sort of what
they're implying I'm all for nuance I
I'm truly all for nuance and I'm all for
protecting a wide um range of debate at
universities I'm I I do actually like
that but what we're seeing
here the the reason these University
presidents can't answer this is not
because they hate the Jews I don't maybe
they do hate the Jews but maybe they
don't I don't I don't think that's what
is motivating their answer right now go
to medishare.com SL Michel m i AEL as a
dailywire listener you're not just
informed you're engaged and sexy you
value freedom and personal
responsibility that's why you got to
check out Medishare Medishare is a
community- based approach to healthcare
that lines up with the principles you
believe in your values matter and with
Medishare your Healthcare dollars will
not be used for medical procedures that
don't line up with your beliefs
Medishare is the highest rated
Healthcare sharing Ministry with a
30-year proven track record it's not
health insurance it's a community of
400,000 believers committed to caring
and sharing with one another members
save up to 50% or more on their monthly
healthcare costs and member satisfaction
surveys show they like Meda share much
more than health insurance why because
it works for a limited time dailywire
listeners will receive a $150 gift card
when they join Medishare to find out
more go to medishare.com that is
medishare.com M AEL terms and conditions
apply right now go to Pac shield.com use
promo code nolles whether you are a
parent a frequent traveler simply an
individual seeking enhanced personal
safety you got to check out pack Shield
Pack Shield is a ballistic insert that
fits into backpacks messenger bags and
briefcases the inserts meet the National
Institute of justice and 3A standards to
stop up to a 44 magnum pack Shield comes
in a variety of sizes and colors so they
can be easily transferred from bag to
bag and way less than most textbooks and
laptops when properly packed in your bag
this remarkable insert can provide an
extra layer of protection I have a
couple of pack Shields the nice thing
about them is that no one can tell me
that I have got this in my luggage
briefcase or bag they just have no idea
they are extremely lightweight and I
love knowing that I am protected it's
stressful to think about a situation
where you might need pack Shield it is
worth it to be ready pack Shield
provides extra piece of mind it's
important to know how to carry it
correctly pack Shield should never be
used for any reason other than personal
defense so packs and protection and
peace of mind with pack Shield check
them out for yourself at pack shield.com
promo code n kwls for 2020% off is Pak
shield.com promo code NOS kwes for 20%
off today what we're seeing here is not
just that they're trapped by their
students which they are they they're
very afraid of upsetting the students
because the students run the show now at
the
universities what they're trapped by
primarily is their own free speech
rhetoric that's the thing and if it were
a different issue being discussed here
the Republicans would be on their
side because they're saying look we
don't you can say whatever you want at a
university and we support Free Speech
now we know that that's bogus that's the
problem here if they actually held to
that rule I would give them credit I'm
not sure I would agree with them I
actually wrote a whole book about how I
disagree with free speech absolutism
called speechless controlling words
controlling Minds do I have a bell on
the road is there a bell
here no okay all right that's fine we'll
have to bring a bell on the road next
time
uh
they they are saying that we don't
unless you actually commit the action of
genocide that would not violate our
policy and then they kind of knew that
was too extreme so they're kind of
walking it back and the reason they're
trying to protect Free Speech here is
because they know that the University
students are very Pro Palestine and
anti-israel so they they want to suck up
to them a little bit as
well we also know that they hate
conservative speakers on campus in fact
I'm I'm not going to say which one one
of the people who was at this hearing I
was invited to this school this semester
and then the administration thrw up a
ton of roadblocks because they don't
want me a completely mainstream
conservative an ordinary American
conservative who just articulates views
that were almost universally held for
almost all of history and especially in
our
country they throw up roadblocks to that
but if I go out and say hey from the
land of the sea kill all the Jews then
this well actually look it's context
dependent you know and actually we need
to protect the right to say
that I want to give them as much credit
as I possibly can if
they seriously have bought their own
rhetoric on Free Speech if they
seriously believe that a university an
educational institution is not entitled
to have standards and norms and to
distinguish between truth and falsehood
and good and bad then they have no
business running a university and two
they violated one of the biggest rules
that one of the most important things
you never teach a child which is never
believe your own press releases the
Liberals in the 60s who ran the Free
Speech movement they didn't really
believe that they just wanted to destroy
conservative norms and standards and and
articulate their their subversive ideas
but the moment that they were able to do
that and crack up the old conservative
standards what did they do they
immediately reinstituted all the speech
codes on their terms to exclude us from
the Public Square and to enshrine their
views as sacran and holy boy what a
great clip that was now hey hey hey ring
that Bell subscribe to the Michael nlls
YouTube channel we'll see you next time